at the entrance to the crane nightclub
friends and family continue to leave
tributes for Cody Fisher the footballer
was stabbed to death on the Dance Floor
now serious concerns have been raised by
police about security at this nightclub
and how the killer was able to take a
knife inside
suspending the club's license Birmingham
city council said the cause of the
serious crime was likely to have
originated from a style of management
which had failed to uphold the licensing
objectives the style of management was
the responsibility of digital arts media
limited as premises license holder of
the crane
on boxing day night there were hundreds
of people inside the club police were
called to reports of a stabbing just
before midnight as the event was coming
to an end
one officer who was among the first to
arrive here said there were hundreds of
small drugs bags and nitrous oxide
canisters all over the floor she
described chaos as Club security asked
police to help them with crowd control
and said as officers rushed to perform
CPR Club staff was starting to clean the
Dance Floor
it all raised this serious questions
mitigation against this sort of crime is
crucial and Security checks in nighttime
economy venues are absolutely imperative
the due diligence around that is very
very important we don't know yet whether
that is the case for this venue whether
there were inadequacies in relation to
that or not it's the investigation needs
to to find that out
the nightclub's lawyer said they take
issue with some of the matters raised
but they didn't oppose the licensed
suspension and said they'd use the time
until a full hearing next month to
develop a better understanding of what
happened
a match due to take place on Monday
between Cody Fisher's current Club
Stratford town and former Club
bromsgrove has been canceled he'd been
out with teammates on the night he was
killed meanwhile police are continuing
to question three men on suspicion of
his murder Becky Johnson Sky News
Birmingham